what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and today we're going to be
talk about ten facts you didn't know
about BOM aka the 25th bomb from Tower
of God if you want to see more tower of
god videos on this channel the best
thing to do is smash that like button
and share this video if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
ring that notification bell or you will
miss future tower of god videos if you
have some specific characters you'd like
to see other fact videos for leave your
suggestions in the comments below
remember that you can get early access
to all of our content including tower of
god content through our podcast anime
opera audio links in the description now
without further ado let's jump into it
for fact number one let's look at the
origin of bomb the author of tower of
god wasn't always going to be a web
manoir artist and if you didn't know
Monroy similar to manga but they're
created in korea rather than japan the
author li zhong hue was born on may 29th
1986 and majored in art education
university afterwards he went for
military service while he was in
military service he met a superior who
liked Manwe and they both started to
draw him on what together it was at this
time that the author would initially
come up with the idea of tower of god
and the character of bomb he came up
with an idea about a boy who came into a
tower chasing after a girl who was his
everything and the tower would test the
boy by the time he finished his military
service he had 10 notebooks full of
ideas and character prototypes that
would one day evolve into the successful
tower of god series there was and
continues to be intense competition in
the webtoon market but the author kept
releasing webtoons for free it took over
six months before he was contacted with
an offer to officially publish the tower
of god series so the story was meant to
revolve around mom and the tower right
from the beginning and fortunately for
us the author made that friend in the
military who fueled his work and love of
manwë if not for him we might have never
come to know bomb and the exciting world
of the tower for fact number two let's
look at bombs birthday bombs full name
is the 25th bomb and we're told that his
name comes from his birthday according
to bomb it was Rachel who actually told
him that his name comes from his
birthday so she seems to know
more than we do since for us Bob's
birthday is classified in fact the
author said that BOMs birthday is the
biggest secret interestingly enough BOM
was initially referred to by head-on as
and I quote the boy who was born on the
night that the tower cried and quote
however it was taken out in later
versions according to the author this
line is for shattering but he decided to
take it out because it might give too
much confusion in the beginning so we
only get some clue surrounding when BOM
was born but it's clearly gonna be a big
deal when we find out we don't know how
old BOM is but we do know that
characters in the Tower of God series
have much longer lifespans than we do
for instance waifu candidate yuri is at
least over 500 years old and there are
characters that are over a thousand
years old this is a unique twist that I
haven't come across often in the anime
I've seen so far for fact number three
let's look at BOMs height Bob's height
changes throughout the story as it
follows his physical and mental growth
his first recorded height is 168
centimeters or 5 feet and 6 inches and
later the author tells us that he
reaches around Koons height which is 181
centimeters or 5 feet and 11 inches thus
he at least becomes around 6 feet tall
and he might not be done growing yet
for instance Yuri is taller than you'd
expect an anime girl like her to be at
180 centimeters or also around 5 feet
and 11 inches tall and the author tells
us that within the tower Yuri is
actually on the smaller side so expect
to see a lot of huge characters as the
series progresses for fact number 4
let's look at BOMs name it has two
meanings in Korean it means night as in
the opposite of day and not the kind of
night who protects damsels in distress
in a suit of armor and bomb also means
chestnut a number of times characters
play on the chest on meaning of Baum's
name and call him tasty Knight also
makes sense with his name since he is
often associated with darkness he came
from a cave after all however it is also
in the night that stars shine and that's
also significant since Baum's been
compared to a shining star as well he
also gains another meaningful name later
on in the series but we won't go into
that here since the anime is
not that far along yet fact number five
bombs voice actor is the twenty
seven-year-old Taichi Ichikawa
from Tokyo Japan he's done more minor
roles in epic shows like men land saga
and JoJo's Bizarre Adventure and golden
wind but the protagonists of Tower of
God is definitely one of his bigger
roles he's made appearances in many
anime so far and I'm sure that we'll see
more of this young up-and-coming voice
actor in the following years and
according to behind the voice actors
calm it appears that the English dub is
going to be done by the veteran voice
actor Johnny Yong Bosch he's voiced many
iconic anime characters including the
loose from Code Geass and Ichigo from
Bleach for my fellow Demon Slayer fans
out there he also voiced the hilariously
antisocial water pillar gear for fact
number six let's talk about how Tower of
God was based on the Shonan genre and
how bomb compares and contrasts with the
conventional shown in hero Shonen is the
most popular demographic for manga
Shonen manga are primarily targeted at
males between the ages of 12 and 18 the
author of tower of god has said that
just as with other shortened
protagonists bomb will undergo internal
and external growth he will realize his
powers in advance farther as he climbs
the Tower of God but the author explains
unlike in Shonen bomb will not push his
Justice or friendship on others bombs
evolving powers won't be used for
something like that thus the author says
that the tower of God's story and
philosophy will be somewhere between
Shonen and seinen Satan is primarily
intended for an older demographic men
from their 20s to 50s just think about
the manga berserk and how you don't
expect to see guts going out of his way
to be friends with people although
powerful bomb is more withdrawn quiet
and unsure of himself and his beliefs
when compared to the average shown in
protagonist for fact number 7 let's talk
about bomb and his connection to jihad
the king of the tower jihad is the
figure that looms over the story even if
we don't see him much we know that he
has beautiful princesses associated with
him that can kick butt and that he's
probably the most powerful but he's
still surrounded in mystery bomb has
been noted to be similar to jihad in his
younger days jihad was also an irregular
the main difference between
- were told is that both sought power to
make people happy but bomb wanted power
so he could stay by the side of his
friends while king jihad wanted power so
that he could stand above others despite
this difference the author said that if
the two characters had met when jihad
was younger they would have gotten along
pretty well but as things stand they
have to have an antagonistic
relationship it's always interesting
when similarities are drawn between the
main character we're supposed to rule
for and the figure that seems to be at
this point at least the final
all-powerful boss of the series for fact
number 8 let's talk about bomb and
Rachel when asked if bomb and Rachel
were dating the author responded that
they aren't and that it's more
complicated than that according to the
author Rachel's not bombs love interest
but a female protagonist and even though
bomb seems like a simple
we're told that he'll be a heartbreaker
and make a lot of women cried before the
series is over fact number 9 bomb has
had multiple hairstyles throughout the
series from shorter hair to longer hair
that covers his eyes fans asked if bomb
would grow his hair long again in the
future and the author asked bomb kind of
how older asks his one-piece characters
questions and lets them respond in his
own question corner into one piece manga
volumes bomb responded that the long
hair is inconvenient so it looks like
it'll remain shorter for the most part
the author added that when he draws both
Koons hair and bombs hair he feels like
giving them a haircut but he knows that
for rock there isn't really anything to
cut fact number 10 as usual will be a
lightening round of sorts I guess we can
dub it the shin-soo round in this case
since we're dealing with hour of God all
lists as many facts about bomb as I can
in a relatively short period of time
three two one let's jam bombs Harry's
brown and his eyes are supposed to be
gold even though they kind of look
orange in the anime bomb is great at
cooking and his best dish is cream
spaghetti he doesn't eat salty stuff or
raw foods but he likes Korean food in
general bombs ambidextrous meaning they
can naturally use his left hand as well
as his right hand but he was still
taught to use his right hand more and
the author tells us that off-screen bomb
does a lot of training making it clear
that he works hard and is not just
expecting his talent to save him and
I definitely learned a lot of things
that I didn't know about bomb as I was
researching this video and I hope you
learned some new facts about him too if
you knew all this stuff then congrats
you are a tower of God stand of the
highest caliber if you did enjoy the
video and want to see more be sure to
smash that like button share this video
let me know what character you would
like to see next
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
belt or you will miss future tower of
god videos remember that you can get
early access to all of our content
including tower of god content on our
podcast anime our audio links in the
description also feel free to let me
know who your favorite Tower of God
character is below I'd love to know
since this series is filled with so many
good ones
lastly the YouTube ad rates has
significantly dropped recently so the
help and support we're getting from our
anime opera patrons is now more
important than ever a very special thank
you goes out to our patrons over on
patreon who help us survive these
YouTube issues and who helped make
videos like this one possible first and
foremost I want to thank the legend
acknowledged by Lord Twigg Oh himself
Efrain aid and the one tier patrons the
ones who stand atop all clans Steven and
Rana a lo'laan often though world
stealers acquire respect potato feh
Jonathan King deci d brandon of miles
papa smurf
the school bus emperor otaku and richie
martinez and our pro hero tier patrons
the one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson King's eldest Anatoly
kozloski angel Cruz hi Sparky sixty-five
cricket XP Ted no Ted Joel Stanton Mary
gucci alicia actor animal 69 jessica
calif on he no kami and water Bonnie
parks Oni are 12 were Thuan de hora
TN Fong Mitch loves anime cynical Kraken
and JCCC wakka thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work to get support
more read by going over to patreon calm
and Mail poor and becoming a patriot
today for as little as one dollar if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to a private patron only discord
where we talk about anime life and of
course dank memes so check out be chong
kham and may uproar a link in the
description if you're interested you can
also now join the YouTube channel and
support more content that way if you
prefer whichever way you choose to
support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again
until next time see us bass Cowboys
[Music]
you